بعد كلامك عن
تايوان أه تقريبا بدا
صدفة خرج الاستطلاع الذي
سألوا الأوروبيين عما إذا كانوا على
استعداد للقتال في تايوان من أجل
تايوان والأغلبية الساحقة من الناس في
أوروبا قالوا لا هل تعتقد أن هذا
يبرر وجهة نظرك
لا، أعني أنني دائمًا ما أكون
حذرًا جدًا فيما يتعلق باستطلاعات الرأي لأنها في بعض الأحيان
تكون جيدة وفي أحيان أخرى تكون سيئة وأعتقد أنه يتعين
عليك
تصميم إستراتيجيتك الخاصة بالإشارة إليها
بالإضافة إلى المصلحة طويلة المدى للجميع
وأعتقد أنه يتعين علينا ذلك  يجب أن
نكون صارمين للغاية فيما يتعلق بقيمنا
ومنظورنا في النظام العالمي
ولكن أعتقد أن هذه الكلمة
تحتاج إلى قدر أقل من التضارب
لأن الأولوية القصوى في جدول أعمالنا
هي إصلاح المشكلات العالمية
أعتقد أن الأولوية القصوى بالنسبة لي في
الأجندة العالمية هي محاولة الإصلاح
الأزمة الحالية،
ومكافحة عدم المساواة في الفقر
وإصلاح تغير المناخ والتنوع البيولوجي،
هذه هي التحديات الرئيسية للاستسلام
المتدهور ولكن على وجه الخصوص في هذا
العقد
أود أن أضيف إلى هذا غرامة واحدة أعني
بناء
إطار جيد وتنظيم مشترك
بشأن الذكاء الاصطناعي هنا  هي
العناصر الأساسية لأجندة عالمية
لتنفيذ هذه الأجندة، نحن بحاجة إلى التعاون،
وخاصة نحتاج إلى التعاون
بين الصين والولايات المتحدة، لقد
وقعنا على اتفاق باريس لأن
الرئاسة والرئيس أوباما توصلا إلى
اتفاق قبل بضعة أشهر إذا لم
يكن هناك اتفاق بين الصين.  والولايات المتحدة
في كل هذه المواضيع، من المستحيل بناء
أجندة عالمية وإصلاح هذه القضايا
هنا هي أهم أولوياتي لأن هذا هو
السبب في أنني أعتقد أنه
بالنسبة للعناصر الحاسمة التي ستؤدي إلى
زيادة
الانقسامات والصراعات
والتوترات بين الولايات المتحدة والصين،
يجب علينا  حاول التخفيف منهم لإيجاد
طريقة
أعني بها المناقشة بهدوء
وبناء الأمور ذات الصلة بها
لتقليل التوترات لأن أولويتنا
يجب أن تكون إصلاح هذه الأمور